right the willingness of Iran to play a
constructive role especially you with
the regard to Saudi Arabia my view is I
think we should not expect too much too
quickly from Iran let's not forget they
have a pretty strong opposition as we
all know they have their own hardliners
let's not have illusions about how
quickly and how resolutely Iran can
actually become a partner in issues
other than the implementation of the
nuclear deal I believe Iran wants to do
that I believe Iran has ambitions to be
a strong and not an isolated power in
the region but I think we need I i love
this word I think we need strategic
patience we need to push them a little
bit keeping pushing them but we
shouldn't get too impatient do you see a
Paragon for a sort of extended contact
group an example in history you would
need to include into this 3 plus 3
format certainly of course Iran you
would need to include Saudi Arabia you
would need to include I think turkey and
maybe other powers so it would be a kind
of a format of that I would like to call
contact group plus to get us started but
the eventual long-term goal needs to be
a larger gathering bringing everybody
from the region around the table I think
of the Afghanistan conference in 2002 13
years ago as as the role as the model
for that do you see a special role for
Germany in this region in this conflict
I hesitate to think of a special role
for Germany but I think Germany as the
central power in Europe and Germany as
the country that used to have the store
longest business relationship economic
relationship with with Iran and given
our new role of responsibility enables
us to help lead the EU so what I think
is Germany can help make the EU a united
and strong and credible actor and
partner this time is really the
responsibility of the EU not just of
Germany